Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, give you another video in our series of gene
understating gene testing why we would do it and what we're looking for.
So try to keep this simple and short.
So bear with me and we're going to go back to biology 101 here though.
What is a SNIP?
What are we looking for when we do a genetic test?
A SNIP defect is a single nucleotide polymorphism.
That's when one gene is changed.
One little nucleotide on a gene is changed.
And remember when we're looking at genes you get one from your mom and one from your dad
and you remember this chart from biology where this is a recessive eye color gene example here.
The mother is recessive for broad eyes.
The father is recessive for broad eyes so they have a large B little B.
Everybody's genes have two alleles.
So they're dominant B and a small B the recessive trait.
And so the child has a 25% chance of actually being dominant for broad eyes,
or a positive, positive for broad eyes, or in this case large B, large B for broad eyes.
And they have a 50% chance of having the exact same as mom and dad having dominant for broad eyes,
and a recessive for blue, dominant for broad eyes, recessive for blue, and thereby having broad eyes.
But they have a 25% chance of being small B, small B, or having blue eyes in this case.
Well we're talking about gene defects.
We're not talking about broad eyes or blue eyes.
We're talking about the gene itself.
Whether that allele is a positive positive or a positive negative or a negative negative,
well, the wild form of the gene in the case of looking at defects as a negative negative,
that's what you want to have.
You don't have any defects.
If you have a positive negative, that means you do have a defect that may not cause any problems, remember.
But it is a defect and it can cause problems if you have a positive positive.
That means you have a double allele defect and that you have a greater chance of it causing problems.
And if it does cause problems, it will certainly, you know,
could be worse than having done at all.
So this is an example of a pathway that we might look at.
There's multiple different pathways.
This is the folate and the methyonide pathway.
And each gene is at that arrow.
If you see the center of my slide there, there's an arrow pointing to a little bubble that says CBS.
That CBS is a gene and that would be one, every one of these bubbles is a gene that we're looking at.
And this is just one little pathway that we look at when we do a 23-metre test and look at all the different genes.
And then we look at whether that's a positive negative or a positive positive or hopefully a negative negative
and we'll cause less problems.
Well, each one of those bubbles is a gene that a gene makes an enzyme usually and that enzyme creates a function within the body.
So you start with a substrate, meaning a chemical compound prior to that gene.
It would interact with that gene enzyme.
You end up with an end product, though there's things that will increase the activity on the left of your slide.
Things that will decrease that activity and that gene also needs, that enzyme needs cofactors.
So different nutrients or minerals or something that will help push that gene.
So things that could increase that activity could be positive, a good thing, or it could be a negative,
if you don't want to be making too much end product.
Things that decrease that activity usually are a negative, they're blocky, that gene function.
And it could be a positive, meaning that's a negative feedback loop that's slow.
We down that gene function because we got too much end product right now.
So that's really what we're looking at when we look at these gene pathways.
So here would be an example, this is the chyrin pathway, where triptophane, by circled green circle there,
is the substrate in this pathway.
Normally, triptophane goes on to make serotonin, but this is what I call a triptophane steel,
where it gets stolen away to go to the IDO1 pathway, that IDO1 gene there.
So this is where it gets taken, triptophane gets stolen,
so it can't create the serotonin that we would to go out to create melatonin to help you fall asleep,
or to use the serotonin in your brain, neurotransmitter, pathways to help call you and keep you happy.
It could stolen instead down this chyrin pathway, and you see the yellowish orgish colored things there.
The INF gamma, the LPS, the stress in the T and F alpha,
well, the INF gamma, LPS in the T and F alpha, are basically inflammatory markers.
LPS lipo polysaccharides, for blood, bacteria, and such, and stress itself,
just emotional, physical, whatever kind of stress that you're dealing with,
could push it down this pathway.
Well, that's not good, because the end product is, it makes chryllidic acid,
which is an excitotoxin to the brain, it causes all sorts of problems.
We don't want to go this pathway, but in the presence of stress and things,
it pushes triptophane, it steals triptophane, it pushes it down this pathway.
Now, in the purple, there it says colm, IL-4, IL-10, that's called bead,
decrease inflammation, those are TH2 cytokines, with a lack of stress,
it helps slow that pathway, and that's what we're looking at.
So, force it this way, create more tyurid and go down to chryllidic acid and cause issues,
and these are things that increase that activity.
So, if we don't want a triptophane steal, we want to stay away from stress
and stay away from inflammatory conditions, and these are things that decrease that activity.
We're going to calm down, decrease our inflammation, but when we are struggling
with a chronic inflammatory source, some chronic infection or something like that,
well, this is why we have problems.
We are happy, we can't go to sleep, we're restless, we're all sorts of,
we're transmitting our imbalances and brain imbalances,
because these are the kind of things that are taking place.
This is why we look at genes, so we give us some answers of why we have problems.
So, we get in summary, genes are things that take substance A,
and turn it into substance B. Now, if there's a defect in that gene,
a single nucleotide polymorphism, either positive, negative, or positive, positive,
which would be worse, then that gene is not going to work very well.
So, substance A is not going to move to substance B very well.
Plus, if you have things in the purple that decrease that activity,
like chronic infections or heavy metal toxicities or a very stressful lifestyle,
even if you didn't have the defect, substance A moves to substance B more slowly,
and that could cause problems.
When your whole purpose of intercellular function is to change different chemicals
from one substrate to another, so that your body can make energy,
so your body can make neurotransmitters, make hormones, detoxify things, et cetera.
It's really important to have these genes function correctly.
So, if we measure, does this person have these gene defects
or these single nucleotide polymorphisms, these SNPs?
Then we could look at, okay, how can we effectively help this person?
Can we decrease the things that decrease the activity?
Can we increase the things that increase the activity?
Can we help with increasing co-factors?
There are some different nutritional lifestyle things that we could change,
and we can really change the outcome.
Let us see, it's a process and it takes time, but it works.
So, that's why we do what we do.
If you have any questions, make sure you call our office.
I hope this explains some things.
And keep watching the rest of our videos.
Go to our office website.
If you're watching this on YouTube,
we got a ton of videos on our website too.
Thanks much, bye-bye.